et
[Musique]
la vieille légende qui avait prédit la
fin du monde et l'arrivée imminente du
monstre shadoks s'est trompé il ne s'est
rien passé pour la punir les shadoks
vont la faire mourir leur du sacrifice
était arrivé la vieille légende petit à
petit se mit à succomber voilà c'est
fait alors il se fit dans le ciel un
grand bruit la lune chance là le soleil
et la terre s'obscurcir
[Musique]
c'était la fin du monde
car c'est vrai c'était le monstre qui
revenait et pour la 7eme croire la fin
des shadoks sauna et oui la vieille
légende avait dit vrai sauf que bien sûr
elle s'était trompée d'une journée mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez des légendes
c'est comme ça oui effet pu siffler les
shadoks temps il n'avait plus envie de
jouer au ray wise est pure et cette fois
je veux pris deux mois mais peine perdue
la fin du nom de lait poursuivaient
zachary terrible est l'approché est
d'approcher un moment lundi 6 à diable b
le mouche un bug il aime à l'état par r
[Musique]
1 les chaloupes sentir que leur enfin
était faux et selon lahcen habitudes
qu'ils avaient en pareille occasion il
sera tête de se pardonner les uns les
autres leurs péchés
le monstre peu à peu émergé des nuées de
vie et oui c'était lui c'était lé vieux
marin shadoks d'autrefois
celui là qui l'avait bannie de la
planète shadoks est condamné à errer
dans les espaces interstellaires erreurs
il les avait retrouvés et le voit la
charité
roger enfin si
et oui c'était lui le monstre a un oeil
que la légende l'avait raconté à s'ils
ne l'avaient pas tuer la vieille légende
peut-être bien qu il ne se serait rien
passé voilà ce que c'est que de tuer une
légende
[Musique]